Hillary Clinton says Martha's Vineyard
situation is literally human trafficking
no one wants open borders on Friday
Hillary Clinton agreed with an MSNBC
Morning Joe hosts assessment that the
sending of 50 migrants to Martha's
Vineyards was human trafficking she
added that nobody wants open borders who
has any idea of how government and
countries work but nobody wants inhumane
terrible treatment of human beings
either what we should be what we should
have been doing is to come together to
reform change and better fund the system
uh by which we deal with these issues
but some people like Governor Abbott of
Texas would rather have an issue than be
a part of the solution I'm sorry Hillary
Clinton how about holding Kamala
accountable to going to the Border they
were doing the same thing before that
yeah the Republican Governors start
doing that they were doing the same
thing they were flying you made a great
point you think we villainizing
immigrants and we're using them as
political pawns that's a great point but
the Democrats have been using them as a
political Pawn the entirety that's how
we got here that's how we got here yeah
including I totally understand where you
come from they they're already political
pawns because most of these people
should have been turned turned away
before they even get here you can't even
come through uh from from what I I might
be wrong on this but if you seek an
asylum in the country you have to first
apply to the country you enter and then
you
progressively get to the United States a
lot of these people are breaking all
kinds of international laws we lived in
Germany at a refugee camp for a year and
a half before we came to the states
literally at a refugee camp in Germany
for a year and a half and then we
finally the day we got our green card to
come here man we were doing backflips
yeah when we knew we were going to be
coming it was like the happiest day of
my life November 28 1990 is when we came
here but I will never forget that day
you made it out uh never I'm telling you
guys how about you how about you me what
his family came here he was born here oh
you was born yeah oh you're lucky I know
yeah
I think he made a good point that it's
all about the message right that's what
you said everything is about the message
right it's not very often I do this but
I have to agree with Adam and that two
wrongs don't make it right I understand
100 what the Santa said I get why he did
it the backlash he did he's proven their
Hypocrites everything but now look at
how this is being flipped on him right
now he's the human trafficker nobody
gives a [ __ ] that they've been flying
illegal immigrants to 49 states across
the country to flip them nobody cares
who does he have to win if he wants to
run for president the Suburban women
right what do the Suburban women look at
and say when they see this Rhonda santis
is a horrible person this is a very
trumpian move of him and he has to be
careful because he's playing with fire
yeah
those those women they love Newsome
right well no you're absolutely right
yeah Gavin Newsom could be present in
2024 because nobody pays attention to
policies anymore right it's a popularity
but I think uh for most of us clearly
look at AOC yeah I mean yeah I think for
the most part when they say human
trafficking it's not human trafficking
that's that's how verbally you know it's
all hyperbole yeah nobody nobody's going
to look that far into it nobody's going
to take it yeah so most people don't
you're right and listen I get what he
did and I think it's great the idea of
it is great right I agree with it but he
has to be very careful because he's
playing with fire and he's giving them
the message what's the alternative
though let me let me ask you a question
what what do leaders do you guys want a
bunch of pansies that are marketers yeah
but this doesn't what does this do this
doesn't solve a lot let me tell you if
I'm on the southern border I'm sitting
there saying thank God he did it and he
ain't even in my state no I want a
leader bro I don't know what world you
guys are living and I'm not trying to
get a if you want to get a CMO as a
president you're not looking for the
right guy the Santa saying the CMO you
can get a you know a lot of different
people to be that job you want a leader
to be the president
half the reason why the mess is taking
place right now with Ukraine potentially
Taiwan that could potentially happen
soon is because ain't nobody afraid of
America today so I don't I don't mind
that he's flexing his muscles by the way
FYI you have to understand this other
part there is risks to you choosing to
be a leader there is risks there's risks
to you showing that you're a true leader
there is a very risk to you being a
tough father there is risks to you being
a high expectation type of a debt
there's risks to you being a guy that
expects a lot from people there's my
kids are going to baseball my son is
going to baseball practice right now and
this place is going I'm standing on the
sidelines just watching to see how these
guys coach the kids and I see hey you
don't come out hey you don't do this run
two laps hey boom five push-ups hey you
dropped the ball five push-ups hey you
didn't do this go run over here at the
end of the two hour practice these guys
are sweating you know what I said on the
sidelines he's in the right place these
are real coaches coaching these guys
they're tough no listen at the end of
the day I don't care about Optics I want
a leader today America is desperately
looking for a leader now don't get me
wrong I'm not telling the centers to go
on a podcast on smoke weed to win some
people that are going to vote for him
I'm not telling you that he's not going
to be doing that but the fact that this
guy's got the audacity to go out there
and do things like that he's showing I
can help solve a lot not only Florida's
problems because people track
record-wise give me one Governor's
resume FYI did you just see what just
happened let me just give you guys a
stat here the does anybody know who just
broke the record for the most money ever
raised by a governor in the history of
America it's a guy named DeSantis so he
just broke the record for the most money
ever raised by a governor in the history
of America his name is Ron DeSantis how
does that happen people from other
states are supporting this guy they
ain't even in here people from other
states so if a guy is going to take a
risk like that I'm for you taking risks
because quite frankly too many people on
all the other sides are playing it way
too safe I want a real leader today I
want a real leader that's going to go
out there so let's let's continue this
conversation with a Newsome call out on
what Newsome just said so Newsome just
came out and said the following which is
on page four
uh Newsome okay so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast
[Music]